Instead of developing your own,
in many cases you can, of course, use somebody else's solver.
There are lots of ready-made software for that.
First of all, there is general mathematical software--
application packages, which can do differential equations,
but which also can do lots of other stuff.
First of all, MATLAB and its clones, such as Octave or SyLab,
Wolfram Alpha if you manage to formulate your problem in one line,
Mathematica, and tons of others.
Second, there is dedicated modeling and simulation software,
such as Simulink, which comes with MATLAB, COMSOL, Multiphysics,
and Wolfram Alpha System Modeler, and PyDS Tool,
which is based on, as the name says, Python.
Then there are lots of code libraries that you can use to build your own application.
One important library to mention here is scipy integrate--
obviously for Python again.
To create plausible motion for games, there are a number of physics engines.
Finally, there are cook books providing snippets of code to be reused or adapted.
The most prominent one of these are the Numerical Recipes.